well the music industry's changing one
because a lot of the people who were
powerful before starting to lose power
and influence because of the shift first
of all we don't sell as many records
anymore
so obviously record stores are going out
of business record labels are selling
over all their revenues are smaller
because even the digital sales don't
make up for the loss in the physical
sales and so everybody's contracting on
the record side so that means recording
labels have smaller budgets that means
the staff staff is smaller they're
they're you know understaffed and a lot
of areas I think and they have to have a
leaner operation and so that means for
an artist that means you get less
support from the record label and you
have to have management and a team
around you that make up for the
difference in what the label used to do
we have to figure out how to do it
ourselves
but fortunately for us there's still
other revenue streams other than making
records
there's touring there's merchandising
there's marketing partnerships and
endorsements and all kinds of sundry
ways to make money and the labels are
realizing that we're making all this
money they're helping us become a star
but we're making money on all these
other areas and so now the new deals
that record labels are signing they're
not just trying to take a piece of the
records they want to take a piece of the
Tauri and they want to take a piece of
the merchandising all the other revenue
streams that come in so it realizing
that the the pie for the actual sales of
Records has gotten smaller they're
trying to take a piece of some other
pies and luckily I signed before that
started happening I haven't had to give
up any percentage of monitoring to my
record label but it I think overall I
think what happens is the artist and the
artist management have to take more
control over the artists career and be
more hands-on with every
vision and be more creative when it
comes to the right partnerships to
market the the artist in the market the
tour and you just can't rely on the
record label as much as you used to
because they're smaller they have fewer
resources and there are so many channels
out there that you can take advantage of
that you can do sometimes just as well
as a regulator for the tunnel I think it
would be fine and start out today at the
end of the day the main difference is
that like I said the record sales are
smaller record labels are smaller but
there's still so much opportunity for a
musician people are listening to music
people are going to concerts people love
music still and that's never going to go
away and people are willing to spend
some money to to get a piece of that
artist whatever that is you know whether
it's a t-shirt or a ringtone or whatever
it is people are willing to spend money
to get a piece of that artist and so no
matter if you're starting now if you're
starting years ago there is opportunity
to do well in the music business you
just have to be a little more creative
now
you